[Musique]
maurice 42 36 96 96 mais surtout soit
pas attention dans un instant philippe
20 ans l'un des trois cent cinquante
mille auditeurs de l'émission pas
rencontré son animateur préféré
[Musique]
alors qu'à sélectionner tout à l'heure
pour savoir quoi non c'était pour te
dire que je vois c'est ça de micro faut
que tu parles devant toi qui connais la
radio non c'était pour te dire que je
trouvais que c'était trop facile le rôle
que tu avais costaud a maintenant c'est
tout oui d'accord comme un téléphone
c'est ça que je voulais voir comme toi
non je vous dis pour la soie maintenant
c'est bon hockey comme au téléphone
voilà dehors c'est ça qui va les voir
non c'est pas c'est ça que tu veux les
voir maintenant tu vois c'est pas ça que
je vais voir tout le monde dehors
maintenant voilà je voulais vérifier tu
as plus vérifiée elle tu disparais d'ici
rapidement
car
ça s'est passé donc de commenter les
fans qu'elle n'accepte pas je dialogue
et
de paix mais il faut il faut moins
accepté d'avoir un dialogue parce que là
j'ai peut-être que c'est parce qu ils
avaient peur de l'entretenir la
conversation quoi mais on agit peut rien
dire comme
ses maîtres donc c'est facile quoi ils
s'imaginent que c'est plus fort et
peut-être que si on avait parlé c'est
moi qui aurait pu lui casser verbalement
donc devra une pas de chance mais il est
assez minable
une sortie qui serait top
salut moi c'est ouais
[Musique]
comme l'a pas reçue ou très peu la
bienvenue comme si je les ai reçus mais
ça c'est parce que tu n'es pas
observateurs à ce moment un reçu mais
très rapidement quoi il est parti un peu
dépité parce que tu n'as pas écouter ce
qui s'est passé je vais te raconter ce
qui s'est passé ce jeune homme qui est
venue était chez lui tout à l'heure a
pris son téléphone et m'a dit ouais moi
je voudrais savoir si quand on convient
qu'on se déplace situé pareil qu'au
téléphone si tu raccroches pareil je lui
ai dit viens il est venu il a dit deux
mots et je les raccrocher comme au
téléphone
parler avec des gens qui n'ont rien à
dire maurice ne supporte pas pour qu'il
réponde pour qu'il ne raccroche pas il
lui faut des conversations qui ait du
sens
peut être quelqu'un d'un naturel
hésitant mais il faut qu'il y ait de la
substance dans son propos pour qu'un
type comme moi puisque et goûter à
partir du moment où il n'y a pas de
succès maintenant propos si simplement
au à la main
voyez passer un stage sur la france 36
heures bon c'est parce que j'ai envie de
vivre
sur la fm ces copies des missions
américaines c'est chaud dit interactif
quand un tabac notamment auprès des
jeunes skyrock justement qui abrite
maurice est l'un des trois grands
réseaux qui avec nrj et fun radio cible
la clientèle des adolescents 8 millions
d'auditeurs potentiels
[Musique]
à thèmes chers à z sylvain et johnatan
moyenne d'âge 16 ans et demi sont tous
des pannes de skyrock les monstres
tabatha cash super nanas lorenzo ou
maurice ils connaissent sur le bout des
doigts
maurice en fait je crois que les gens
qui l'écoutent enfin moi je les écoute
c'est assez souvent un
peu comme vous voyez un gladiateur qui
vont dans une arène est en fait il ya à
maurice le monstre il ya le gladiateur
qui arrive c'est l'auditeur qui essayent
de battre maurice quand on fait un peu
failli sa rapport de force sur tout
mais tu comprends qu'on puisse appeler
se faire jeter continue à l'appeler bien
sûr c'est du masochisme
non parce que maintenant c'est un défi
j'ai appelé plusieurs fois bon début je
me suis fait jeter parce que moi même au
risque en a pas maurice morgue et après
quand on a quelque chose à dire ça passe
sylvain à thème et johnattan téléphone
régulièrement à maurice wata matin la
seule de la bande à ne pas avoir franchi
le pas c'est shiraz aide
et je dirais pas qu'ils n'en aient pas
venu mais je n'éprouve pas le besoin
donc en route avant j'écoutais souvent
ben quand je rentre des cours en faisant
mes devoirs je me la radio systématique
et qu'est ce que tu en penses de
l'émission de tomates a par exemple elle
peut aider beaucoup de gens donc je
pense que série pas de mal donc les
thèmes abordés les mots crus ça donne
pas du tout parce que y'a que ça c'est
papale peu de censure et puis que
puisque ce qu'a dit à la radio on dit en
trio comme elle le dit elle même elle a
des paroles crues mais dépenser scène la
sodomie les odeurs de l'amour l'amour
sans pénétration des jeunes normaux
basse et des thèmes ce détail qui sont
demandées par les éditeurs source où
vous vous en parler ailleurs ou juste la
radio non j'entends partout enfin plutôt
la radio parce qu'en parler avec mes
copains les copines ça fait un peu mal
quand même tu parles on parle d'autre
chose que de la sodomie et avec tes
parents même pendant qu'ils sont assez
cool ils parlent de tout mais bon on est
à table c'est sûr très pâle si j'étais
sensation la cedh a mis tous les quatre
préfère la radio à la télévision
il trouve que le ton y est moins rigide
et l'accès à l'antenne plus patient en
effet pour poser dans le poste qu'il
suffit de décrocher son téléphone
l'émission que ça fait super nana c'est
le week-end c'est à la place de maurice
même avant et c'est là yan li ya un truc
qui s'appelle année les intrus qui
durent un certain temps il ya plein
d'auditeurs qui s'appellent entre eux et
quand vous écoutez c'est vraiment du
délire quand tout le monde est la
protéine rhés pour déconner comme ça on
se libère de tout ce qu'on fait pas
qu'on va pas faire dans la vire j'ai
envie de dire à un mec à la radio est un
canard et jeudi à la radio il fait pas
qui je suis anonyme aussi fait bonsoir
ouais tu veux parler de quoi
ouais mais l'amour c'est grand quoi leur
royal de l'afm en tout cas pour les
radios dites de jeunes c'est entre 19 et
22 heures
c'est le skate club jusqu à 21h16 1 42
36 96 deux fois celle numéro téléphone
vous appelez vous dit absolument ce que
vous voulez et en plus ce soir c'est les
bonnes ou les mauvaises odeurs de
l'amour définit le sky club émission
réservée aux adolescents que l'appel de
la sexualité titi est animée par
frédéric au le toubib et tabatha cash
soir
tabatha cash à 21 ans avant de faire de
la radio c'était une star du porno
passé sébastien
[Applaudissements]
une [ __ ] à une fellation
najac
la tiennent donc voilà est ce que tu te
laves oui bien
correctement et que nous savons avec
tous les jours
le soir est ce que peut-être que je veux
dire ça sent mauvais bon bah si même si
tu t'es laver le matin si tu as fait un
sport dans l'après midi beaucoup
d'enfants n'a plus lancé en septembre
dernier pour concurrencer les missions
de doc et difool sur fun radio loving
fun
le temps du skate club est devenu au fil
des semaines un peu plus haut violemment
critiquée pour sûr langage converse
tabata a mis un bémol à la provoc 21h
avec une tabata le toubib frederico
skyrock j'ai changé mon petit peu ma
manière de pas mais pourquoi est ce que
vous trouviez vous même que c'était hors
de moi ouais c'est même pas non pas que
c'était 3-2 mais ce cas c'est que
ça me plaisait plus voilà et je crois
qu'il faut faire mais il faut parler et
vivent comme on le sent donc parler
comme je parlais ya encore quelques
temps bah je sais pas ce que je le
sentais c'est ce qui me convenait et
puis ça me convient plus donc je me suis
arrêté mais j'ai changé de voulais pas
me reprocher de dire ça si j'ai si je
regarde tous si j'écoute tout ce qu'on
me reproche quoi je me tire une balle
dans c'est le cadet de mes soucis ce
qu'on raconte autour de moi sur moi
comment vous concevez votre rôle dans
cette émission d'interactivité ou à des
adolescents qu'ils appellent ou des
jeunes alors d'abord je le conçois
certainement pas comme eux
messi ni
maire de mères d'adolescents ni deux ni
de représentante des jeunes non je suis
uniquement un avis voilà un avis un avis
sur tout sur tout ce qui évoque les
dents
en trente missions
vous entendez vous écouter la radio
dehors parce que justement attendait
quelqu'un et puis
voilà on attendait tabatha cash on va
entendre quelque chose qu'on lui a
offert un cadeau qu'est ce que vous avez
offert comme cadeau ben ces trucs un peu
environ en lui l'a offert c'est un
règles propres mesuré
et
moi c'est un contraceptif masculin c'est
marrant c'est qu'ils otx car frontières
protéger nos emplois
pendant que leurs parents regardent la
télévision environ 600000 adolescents et
tabata sur skyrock et plus d'un million
trois cent mille doc et difool sur fun
radio
[Musique]
shekou sky servadou john james et radio
ça fait cinq ans
non non pas du tout pas petite série
coûte n'est pas réparé mais j'ai j'ai
certes elle conflit avec mon père ce qui
s'est passé comme tout le monde le sait
la censure
des gens conclut
conflit entre jeunes et personnes âgées
je veux pas dire vieux pas péjoratif
mais
c'est des conflits comme ouais
t'es un as tu écoutes auraient deux naze
or mon époque et où on parle de lancer
le pavillon crs on vous laisse vous
savez ce que vous voulez faire
une accepte et sa petite soeur écoutent
écouter en cachette vous mais pas que tu
saches pas
c'est vrai un c'est surtout tabatha cash
j'ai pas loin moi j'écoute mais moi
comment tu as donc on va raconter ne
vois pas pourquoi je ne veux pas
parce qu'ils trouvent que c'est trop
hard et vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
bah j'aime bien ça dépend des jours
quelquefois c'est il exagère quelque
fois ça va
qu'est ce qui vous plaît
ce qui m'a fin au début ce que j'ai bien
aimé c'est parce que tout le monde en
parlait alors je me suis dit mon
massiges tout le monde le fait pourquoi
pas moi puis après c'est pas du tout à
cause de ça je vais bien je trouve qu on
a l'air sympa mais ça cache tout à fait
naturel non mais ça vous intéresse des
thèmes sexuels la pause bah je ne mets
que j'écoute ça que quand je serai grand
je sais pas du tout ce que savait ce que
ces bombes à sam avertit déjà ce que je
vais voir ce serait un petit peu plus
grand et filles c'est pas mieux d'en
parler avec votre famille non je n'y
arriverai jamais jamais voilà tu trop
enfin surtout que mon père ne savait pas
quoi et avec votre mère donc ma mère
elle est capable d'en parler mais j'ai
j'oserais pas la mère de daniel 13 ans
et johnatan 17 ans et léa 44 ans qui
cherche et
je comprends ce
parce que les enfants je crois que
souvent ils préfèrent parler avec un
l'étrangère qui avec des parents
peut-être cpie dit que je sais pas mais
je crois je crois que c'est naturel
c'est normal mais membres de ma part
j'aurais bien voulu écouter ses
problèmes
avec mon fils peut-être aussi à mais ma
fille mais souvent j'attends que mon un
téléphone à la radio et j'ai j'écoute
tout ce qu'elle dit ah vous l'écoutez
quand il parle à la radio
ça m'a mise ça vous surprend
non c'est la génération ses clés comme
ça maintenant c'est vrai qu'ils ont des
mots crus un oui mais tout ce qu'ils
écoutent la radio c'est normal ils
répètent tous qu'il écoute
moi j'essaie toujours de comprendre mes
enfants sur ses côtés même si je dis que
quand j'écoute skyrock je crois que ça
me choque commun de tout autant mais
j'essaie d'être
tolérant pour pas oublier que non les
quinze ans tabata sur skyrock doc et
difool sur fon le principe elle-même
donné la parole aux adolescents derrière
le micro christian spitz pédiatre 44 ans
dit le dock et david massard 26 ans
surnommé difool
lancé au printemps 92 loving fun
traduisent l amour sans s'embêter et
l'émission qui part de funradio une
émission bien rodé où le dock joue le
rôle du médecin sérieux je suis tandis
que de son côté difool vous celui du
copain à l'esprit pas y'a pas je ne sais
absolument pas comment réagir et pour
des moins vite doc il ya d'autres jours
de renvoyer dans la semaine et puis à
d'autres saint valentin bonne fête c'est
des échecs ne faut pas prendre les
échecs négativement c'est toujours
positif c'est vrai que sur le coup ça ne
fait pas plaisir du tout la pression
finale on n'est pas capable de séduire
une fille ou l'aimé mais bon ça passe
tout le monde des échecs de ce jour sur
les 8000 appels reçus chaque soir aux
standards les animateurs nan parce
qu'une 40 ces gens ont parfois ces
pêcheurs c'est d'ailleurs en marche
dernier le csa voulu syrie mais les
appels en direct fiq les adolescents ont
crié à la censure et le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel a fait marche
arrière charlot c'est laurent bonjour tu
n'appelles de epernon va bien
[Musique]
très bien que 13 ans c'est ainsi qu'une
ont commencé à quand un conduit de
grossir quand on parle d'art
nous en doute la puberté vient de
démarrer sur des points qui sont
apparues et pas très longtemps
ça commence à pousser tout doucement
bien tout simplement d'utiliser en cours
de puberté tu mesure combien
donc tu vas encore quand on dit a
probablement fait regarder la courbe de
croissance est en pleine puberté est
normalement l'évacuation vient enfin de
puberté merci laurent et aux détracteurs
à ceux qui trouvent que les propos tenus
sur l'antenne peuvent parfois frisé la
pornographie christian spitz répondent
qu'ils ne vont pas assez souvent dans
les cours de récréation en tous cas
scott fun radio rubrique direct ses
téléphones et la bombe humaine c'est
libre antenne
parle sans détour ils parlent de leur
vie celle en face en me parlent et
s'expriment comme ça sans détour à la
radio mais il n'y a pas de perversion
dans leur langage est pas du goût de la
provocation dans ce qu'ils me disent les
emplois ces mots là mais ce n'est pas
lié ce n'est jamais gratuit parlent
d'eux-mêmes donc moi personnellement je
dirais simplement une chose
j'écoute ce qu'ils disent parce que ça
parle de leur vie c'est pas pour ça que
je parle comme ça c'est tout et je ne
les vois pas du tout travaillé et de
gêner soit une déperdition parce qu'elle
parle comme ça où la jeunesse est
toujours à langage à elle qu'elle
s'invente un chèque génération bien sûr
ça c'est certain et puis parle de la
sexualité avec des goûts très très fort
parce que c'est une préoccupation à cet
âge à quai comme importante et il s'agit
encore une fois j'ai dit souvent d'une
violence peut-être dans les mots mais il
ne faut pas assimiler à des actions ne
sont pas des actes c'est important des
gens
des gens qui rient des gens qui rêvent
cette parole ordinaire que certains
citoyens estime confisquer ce besoin
d'exprimer sur les médias autre chose
que le ronron officiel ou fm l'utilisent
depuis octobre dernier comment tout
simplement par l'intermédiaire de 500
correspondants bénévoles qu'elle a
équipé de bebo ainsi des étudiants des
commerçants mais aussi des marginaux
peuvent s'exprimer sur 99.9 tenait
casquette par exemple restent des êtres
à la sensibilité d'un anarchiste est
devenu l'une des vedettes de
l'expérience le sujet favori de ces
chroniques la rue son domaine
il ya des gens qui ont squatté un
immeuble servait à rien du tout et puis
de
tas de choses tu fais
ta pouvant d'un côté et qui essaye de te
juguler et puis de l'autre côté
tu as toi qui veux dire simplement les
venez je dépoussière de toiles plein les
mains sur 10 lui à tout le monde
laissez moi le faire mais non on vit
assez elle te briser l'image de les
fermer à coups de matraque ou de lois ou
n'importe quoi
phosphore ckoi et la rue du dragon
c'est
peut-être limoges de quelque chose qui
va prendre un essor que j'espère
continue rang
j'espère qu'il y aura d'autres dragons
parce que c'est vachement important on
en voit beaucoup des rubriques des coups
de fil à eupen au fmi et que je vois
quelque chose
des fois ça me rend triste comme l'autre
fois c'était
un jeune de 18 ans qui est mort
d'overdose
et puis une fois c'est des trucs avoir
légué les gens qui sont heureux
coup de gueule coups de coeur les
chroniqueurs amateurs de fm peuvent
intervenir plusieurs fois par jour sur
l'antenne la station qui fouette les be
bop et paye l'abonnement téléphonique
reçoit plus de quarante appels par jour
c'est l'écho de la vie au quotidien
celui de la part l'ordinaire
l'état
au fil des jours et comme casquette
leone a lui aussi pris goût au jeu léon
à 60 ans et c'est le petit cordonnier de
la rue de charonne est composé de
fronton retrouver dans les classeurs
dans les tiroirs et donc souvent les
personnages et les lieux ont disparu
chaque semaine il envoie cinq ou six
chroniques à radio sujets de société eco
de la vie artistique du quartier édito
sur l'artisanat tout l'intérêt d'être
consultés pour à disposition
québec québec
non
j'ai été très amusé par cette expérience
vous aviez envie de prendre la parole
peut-être inconsciemment mais moi je
suis déjà que je suis un curieux de
nature tout m'intéresse
pour que pourra apaiser cette curiosité
il faut parler il faut communiquer et
parler avec des gens d'ici dans le
commerce ici je seul artisan
je vois du monde on a besoin de
communiquer en a besoin de parler et la
seule façon de parler c'est de prendre
la parole donc c'est ce que j'ai fait
enfin vous l'avez bruit parce qu'on
voulait donner la parole mais c'est sûr
japon a été la volée comme l'a proposé
mais il fallait l'accepter et j'ai pris
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'interactivité en général justement des
émissions comme l'iphone ou tabata
je pense que c'est très instructif moi
je pense que il faut parler il faut on
nous a fait la parole existe à lire un
livre c'est pas pareil on est tout seul
avec l'auteur mais interpellé quelqu'un
lui parler si les gens parlaient plus
dans la rue mais ça irait beaucoup mieux
si au lieu de en voiture si il se
faisait un signe d'amitié au lieu de
s'engueuler mais ça serait beaucoup
mieux ils se parlent pas assez
l'interactivité c'est ça c'est de faire
des pour nous qui sommes tous derrière
notre poste de téléphone faire dévier le
cours des choses ne pas laisser le
ronron s'installer je pense qu'on peut
le faire rsa lui ses casquettes
bon je te vois un petit truc âme qui bip
ouais ok c'est nos problèmes ouais
au bipe ouais ça roule
petit glissement de fréquences et on
passe sur europe 1 avant ce qui sépare
dont une bonne action corinne à 30 ans à
la [ __ ] les lilas c'est ça quand il
annonçait une nouvelle à ton mec
c'est
le premier tu deuxième jaune est bien là
il va être content tu crois ok on
l'appelle tout de suite à l'eau bruno
oui mais cela radio
tu as assurant par bruno
oui certains oui mais la radio alors mal
entendantes à radio
[Applaudissements]
radio maintenant bruno tué la voiture
d'une terrible nouvelle à t'annoncer
ses confidences et retiennent cette
annonce faite à bruno par
l'intermédiaire de la radio ayant de
quoi surprendre nous avons rendu visite
à la famille haouzi alors bruno d'abord
j'étais content parce que c'est vrai que
ma femme est enceinte pour ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle j'étais content parce que
c'était cet original comme idée et puis
que ça change
lorsque tu rentres à la maison on te dit
sa femme talons ce que tu un bébé c'est
sympa aussi mais bon c'est vrai il par
la dernière à la radio par effet trouvé
ça original ça m'a plu et comment et
pourquoi vous avez cette idée ou
d'appeler europe parce que je trouvais
ça original
j'écoute arthur depuis
quelques années déjà j'avais envie de
pour la troisième naissance quoi de
faire quelque chose hors du commun mais
l'annoncé autrement quoi et comme je
sais qu'ils écoutent arthur et quillan
bien donc puis-je avec arthur addey le
tourner un petit peu en dérision donc
finalement c'est ce que je voulais c'est
à dire le tourner en dérision moi je
savais qu'ils allaient blagué là-dessus
bon automatiquement quoi donc ça me
plaisait
non parce que des gens qui peuvent être
surprises c'est ce que je dis à votre
mari on peut s'attendre que pour
annoncer la naissance d'un enfant ça
sera plutôt dans l'intimité pour
partager sa vie oui on les 2e et 2e
c'était plus dans l'intimité mais bon le
troisième
je sais pas point de nous le troisième
c'était autre chose quoi ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle et donc
pour moi c'était puis j'ai envie de
faire la surprise comme ce à quoi j'ai
plusieurs amis qui coûtait sa ké fouté
division et que en fin de compte tout le
monde là si en même temps quoi ouais
j'ai pas eu à appeler celui ci ou celle
là où certaines personnes comme
l'assurent même temps au contraire c'est
même mieux que moi que le soir il ya un
moment même ils vont raconter qu'ils ont
eu un doute parce que est ce que c'était
qu'un produit le bon bruno ce que
c'était bien corée est-ce que c'était
bon et non ses moi je trouve ça je
trouvais ça se trouve ça très bien ça
évite des terres par
wes a vu de lui faire part non mais je
trouvais ça vraiment très bien il va
s'appeler comment tient bonne question
le plus surpris de ces confidences c'est
l'animateur arthur
c'est terrible parce que on a souvent
des exemples de confidences que nous
font nos auditeurs que moi
personnellement je n'arriverai pas à
faire à une autre personne qui au
principal intéressé quoi et là il peut y
avoir 200 300 milles 1 million
d'auditeurs il balance comme s'ils
étaient seuls ça veut dire aussi que ils
ont l'impression de me parler en tête à
tête ce qui est très bizarre ils sont
pas conscients du fait qu'il ait
énormément de monde qui écoute bizou
alors qu'ils sont exhibitionnisme
exhibitionniste mai mais il faut
vraiment se méfier c'est pourquoi
l'interactivité aujourd'hui à la radio
il faut vraiment la prendre avec des
pincettes parce que si vous prenez une
journée de radio c'est de vous
enregistrer de 6 heures du matin à
minuit toutes les radios et c'est ça le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que vous
entendrez le même mec raconter la même
histoire sur toutes les radios et c'est
pourquoi moi j'ai pris la décision
probablement d'arrêter l'année prochaine
ce type de fonctionnement c'est qu'il ya
une partie exhibitionniste tels que le
gamin viennent raconter une histoire
terrible entre 16h et 18h et le même
type va raconter la même sur fun radio
et puis demain matin sur skyrock est en
fait il ya ce besoin comme disait warhol
d'exister de briller au moins deux
minutes sur un média et et c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui est en train de lui dire de
pourrir le concept de l'interactivité
c'est qu'il ya peut-être des gens qui
ont vraiment besoin de parler de se
confier mais ils ne sont que 10 % par
rapport à ce qu'ils appellent juste pour
passer à la radio
n'oubliez pas le slogan du jour les
malades du sida sont légende comme les
[Musique]
avec plus de 4 millions d'auditeurs
énergie est le premier réseau jeunes de
l'afm ici on a toujours privilégié le
robinet à musique les animateurs de
génération x une émission à l'humour
parfois féroce le regrette même un peu
pour l'avenir un savant dosage entre les
mots et les notes je pense que les
radios qui
les radios fm sont pour l'instant alors
préhistoire et qu'on arrivera plus tard
à des radios mature qui arriveront à
mixer les deux c'est à dire paroles et
musique mais voulait justement qui avait
un humour un peu féroce de temps en
temps est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
tout dire ou es ce que vous avez une
autocensure ou est-ce que vous vous
limitez quand même dans la parole on a
de temps en temps une autocensure mais
en fait on veut penser c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être un rêve on veut penser
qu'on peut tout dire on aimerait penser
qu'on
on en rêve on aime censeurs de forme
dans le fond on n'a aucune censure ce
cas dans l'esprit on ne pompe pas avoir
de sens sur la vie d'envoi tout on
entend tout donc on a tous dans la tête
et on essaie on arrive avec tout
malheureusement on fait parfois donc
c'est là qu'intervient la censure c'est
dans le propos il s'agit pas de blesser
les gens ni d'en faire du mal même de la
peine même même des oscars du porno
qu'on les gros nichons n'y avait aucune
raison de leur faire du mal de ses deux
enfants - son voile annoncé que
à chaque fois que j'ai pris conscience
de la réalité c'était c'était grâce à
des gens qui m'ont initié avec de
l'humour donc à partir de là je veux que
ça les meilleures façons 0,6
du coup c'était là
et on peut tout dire même sur l'histoire
de skyrock avec le l'animateur qui a
parlé comme ça c'est pas de lui cet
homme c'est pas dur et pas drôle du tout
dire que mon patron il a fait rire
personne et je pense que même en le
disant il s'est dit qu'est ce que je
raconte je pense qu'il avait dû boire un
pastis de trop ou donc en vente peut
tout dire dans l'humour dans l'humour il
faut que ça soit il faut que ça soit
drôle est que ça réveille la conscience
des échanges s'est alors dit quelque
chose mais que ça fasse rire
tu n'es pas raciste
ça ne te gêne pas de marché à visage
découvert
aime rire lire écrire faire l'amour
tu adores recevoir de l'acide sur les
jambes quand tu portes une vue
tu supportes d'avoir un couteau dans la
gorge
alors toi aussi devenez
femme libre en pays intégristes
l'humour la dérision la provocation pour
certaines radios fm c'est seulement une
stratégie commerciale c'est d'ailleurs
la stratégie avoué de pierre bellanger
le patron de skyrock parfois ça passe
parfois comme le 3 janvier dernier
lorsqu'un de ses animateurs s'était
réjoui de la mort d'un flic à l'antenne
ça casse quand on fait de l'humour
l'amour la provocation c'est que c'est
quoi c'est généralement un propos aux
dépens d'autrui c'est à dire qu'on se
fout de la gueule de quelqu'un et on se
marre bien fort bon ça c'est le principe
de l'humour en même temps il ya un autre
principe qui est celui du respect
d'autrui c'est la règle minimale moral
respectez les autres danses qui sont
dans leur comportement la personnalité
bon donc comme ce sont deux principes
contradictoires si on veut faire une
radio qui est provocante on doit mettre
des balises en disant non bien sûr tel
thème on te le thème on n'intervient pas
sur tel thème on le laisse à l'extérieur
et donc voilà comment on avance donc non
on ne peut pas tout dire les autres à la
radio soit parce que la régulation le
droit le l'interdît soit et c'est
généralement dans la majorité des cas
parce que nous mêmes nous ne le
souhaitons pas et parce que les
auditeurs ne le souhaite pas quand il ya
des excès qui sont fait à l'antenne les
auditeurs le sanctionne donc on est dans
une logique ou comme disait cocteau sans
arrêt on voit jusqu'où on peut aller
trop loin et c'est vrai que il ya une
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'expression c'était face à lui ça
déborde mais c'est vrai que cette
liberté n'existe que parce que des gens
responsables derrière dans chacune de
trois stations pour la faire fonctionner
qu'est ce qu'est devenu l'animateur qui
a dérapé sur la sphère du policier
abattu eh bien il a souhaité arrêter ses
activités de radio pourquoi parce que
c'est certain que reprendre l'antenne à
la suite de ces événements et essayer
d'être léger caustique et c'est avec une
pression considérable
c'était difficile donc à vous qu'il
avait envoyée non on a eu un commun
d'accord là dessus pour 10 rebonds
comment est ce qu'on en a vu les choses
comme étant difficile à continuer comme
on avait prévu de le faire au départ
[Musique]
quelques semaines après skyrock c'est au
tour de son concurrent direct fun radio
d'être aujourd'hui dans le collimateur
du csa
cette fois le sujet de plaisanterie ce
début la mort d'un policier c'est le
camp d'auschwitz et réflexions entre
guillemets de l'animateur de fun à
propos de schwyz vous savez c'est le
rêve de bon mal de gens des maisons de
campagne oui moi j'en ai une très jolie
à vous proposer est ce qu'une maison de
campagne qui est l'abandon maintenant
faut retaper la toiture un sacré hausse
aux hausses des hausses vite si vieille
baraque des années 40 alors le nec qui
l'avait il est très très riches david
weiss chemin de fer avec genre de mec
arrive être érigés tout
le tout nouveau président du csa se dit
indignée hervé bourges ne prend pas la
faire à la légère il a aussitôt écrit au
directeur de la radio ils demandent si
le csa s'indigne l'auditeur moyen ne
s'étonne pas de ces dérapages pour lui
tout cela est dans la logique du système
u la radio skyrock radio quittant bat
son plein
bavure à mon avis vas-y quand il laisse
couler c'est bon sens et médiatique à
mon avis qui fera la plus grosse
connerie qui va toucher la plus grosse
[Musique]
grosse offre
vous écoutez quoi alors moi je suis plus
branché radio aux gentils europe 2 rfm
que ça parle pas trop et qui a plus de
musique est bon à l'origine mais la
radio pour écouter la musique et les
conneries
employer les événements évoqués pour
cauet 23 ans l'auteur des propos
incriminés a été licencié de pôle radio
est bien évidemment il regrette d'avoir
tenu ces propos choquants et ce en
excuses les explications qu'il donne à
son dérapage celle d'un automobiliste
conduisant une voiture trop rappliquent
on est sur une ligne qui est la ligne du
tolérable car on peut le faire ça on
peut on amuse les gens et puis quand
vous allez vite quand vous êtes sans
texte comme moi se fait des années que
je faisais de l'improvisation quand vous
dites des choses allaient très vite et
un moment donné voici par exemple ce qui
s'était passé à ce moment là ce avait
une sorte de flash vous dit où là c'est
quelqu'un se branche à ce moment-là ce
quelqu'un arrive qui ne me connaît pas
qui n'est pas un auditeur fidèle qui
sait pas qui est qu elle fasse dire mais
qu'est ce qu'il raconte est là et là
j'ai eu mais ça dure très vite c'est
dire comme vous êtes en direct vous
pouvez pas vous arrêter mark est un
blanc et dire je reviens sur ce que j'ai
dit avant c'est impossible donc encore
une fois très vite à 200 à l'heure faut
trouver un truc qui diminue qu'ils
fassent une conclusion au sérieuse là où
vous voulez en arriver parce qu'on se
rendus compte qu'on a été un petit peu
mais je descendais ça a été très vite et
vraiment ça a été très vite c'était ce
que je vous disais à l'instant c'était
peut-être que je pour quelqu'un qui
vient d'arriver va peut-être pas
comprendre et c'était ça c'est toujours
le problème des gens qui se branchent
constamment qui allument leur poste
s'ils ont ils ont l'air on leur a paru
situé avant pour situer tout à lui
totalement mon émission ils peuvent pas
savoir que ce que je dis est à prendre
au second degré que je joue un rôle que
joue le rôle d'un débile qui voit une
photo ils ont peut-être se dit remis les
courges tony matters ne pas reconnaître
de parler de auschwitz c'est c'était çà
et là justement sur cette ligne mais
j'ai mis un pied à côté
il est trop tard quand vous aimez le
piège et vous le retirez la marque la
trace reste
devant ces débordements certains
pourraient penser comme vini que seul le
silence est grand ce serait excessif la
fm comble indéniablement un vide utile
donc mais à condition comme le dit le
père guy gilbert tout à la fois prêtre
éducateur social et animateur de radio
de savoir prendre du recul
ce cas pas trop de mots à la radio si si
il ya overdose de moi même mais je
dirais que c'est la profondeur de ta vie
intérieure de ce que tu vis à
l'intérieur de toi même qui peuvent
donner un poids au mot oui moi je crois
oui sinon autrement on risque de faire
un verbiage extraordinaire ne plus
écouter dire des tas de choses et
finalement nous devons donner un poids
aux mouches croix et pour ça il faut que
tu es un espace de silence et normes
pour pouvoir donner après une parole
énorme je crois et vous pensez de 2,7 de
monde parce qu apparemment tous ces gens
qui ont envie de s'exprimer à la radio
mais on s'en sentait un besoin de moore
de parole
tu as un besoin de mots mais tu as
besoin de certitudes
dans une émission les gens te demande
des repères des garde-fous des des
limites et c'est dans ce sens là quand
tu es l'homme des repères l'homme des
garde-fous l'homme des limites l'homme
des impasses et en or faut pas aller
trop loin
j'entends assez souvent des gens qui
parlent des jeunes et en leur répondant
dans leurs questions qui sont regnault
ce niveau sax à tous niveaux amour et
ces drogues fais ce que tu veux comme tu
sens est la dernière des conneries à
dire à mon avis mais dire par moments
l'adulte doit dire non ne va pas jusque
là voilà je crois que ça s'est laissé
l'adulte qui manque le plus aujourd'hui
la radio sur laquelle travaille dit
gilbert c'est radio notre dame 100.7
sur cette fréquence tous les dimanches
matins depuis quatre ans les personnes
qui ont des amis ou de la famille en
prison peuvent envoyer des messages
derrière les murs
il était décédé dimanche dans l'émission
s'appelle le téléphone du dimanche ici
la radio met en contact ceux de
l'extérieur avec ceux de l'intérieur
comme d'habitude
et je vous souhaite un bon dimanche
martin qui appelle tous les dimanches
pour laisser des messages à son mari
incarcéré depuis plus de 15 ans nous a
expliqué l'importance de cette émission
de radio
dimanche martin c'est très important
c'est quand ils sont en isolement au
mitard ses seuls moyens de communiquer
ou quand on n'a pas de permis de visite
présentant de la voix je vois mon mari
enregistre les cassettes et puis il se
repasse l'après-midi enfin
moi j'écoute reddition
c'est dur très dur
c'est dur mais bon c'est un des points
et puis
ça voilà ça permet de il faut salle et
ça les aide mais moi je passe d aider
des messages à des amis qui n'ont pas de
compacts parloir quand les parents qui
sont laissées par les femmes qui se
retrouve tout seul quoi passer des
messages pour votre mari ou plutôt de
poulet et d'autres prisonniers aussi
ouais
ouais et en plus si pour principe plutôt
être en forme quoi il faut être en forme
faut craquer avant de craquer africain a
raccroché le téléphone
ouais je vous en prie
c'est aussi cela l'interactivité pas
je t'ai fait son sentiment d'un juste
avant de partir
et j'ai pensé
[Applaudissements]
et puis c'est facile mais bon c'est
l'intervention avait mangé du cabinet
pas obligé de me déplacer des agents de
pour faire voir
vous êtes bénévole vous n'êtes pas payé
pour faire cette émission on est
bénévole aurait en effet chaque dimanche
et revient plus consacrer une heure et
demie à l'émission voilà c'est
extrêmement émouvant quand l'émission
oui c'est émouvant parce que ce sont des
parce que je crois que c'est
ça des gens qui sont dans la peine des
familles et puis aussi ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur et puis à mur qui les sépare
donc le franchir aussi c'est entre le
franchissent avec toutes leurs pelles et
puis ça fait un contact parce que le
dimanche est un peu genre particulier en
détention il ya aucun mouvement ya pas
de ya pas deux
le parloir il n'y a pas d'avocats ya pas
de cours et à rien donc c'est une
journée morte et c'est vrai que fait de
recevoir à l'intérieur c'est
d'entendre les voix de ceux qui les
aiment c'est important puis ça montre
aussi qu'ils sont pas abandonnées qu'il
ya plein de gens qui conseillent
énormément tu peux pas t'imaginer comme
actuellement à chaque fois je préfère
mon petit coeur
et puis surtout ya ces
allées on respire respire un tout petit
peu rires un petit peu d'énergie
des sourires dans l'air c'est dans
chaque particule alors si vous respirez
vont venir il y a ceux de l'extérieur et
puis ceux de l'intérieur comme rené
incarcéré à fleury-mérogis sous le
numéro d'écrou de à 289 e
[Applaudissements]
j'enregistre toutes les missions
qu'après que j'ai mon message je vis
dans mon visage je serais tu laisses est
ce que c'est le message vous les
repasser temps en temps ça arrive une
fois tous les quinze jours il faudrait
trois semaines bon bah je me repasse ont
des messages mais bon ça me fait du bien
parce que c'est
c'est vivant sinon c'est la voix qui
vient de l'extérieur pour ceux qui sont
à l'intérieur comme le nom de l'hymne
national dick
ça fait quand même beaucoup plus plaisir
que de recevoir de l'aide
les bruits qui rythme l'interview de
rené ce sont ceux que font les gardiens
en train de sonder les barreaux des
fenêtres des barreaux qui laisse
seulement passer les ondes vers siel
[Applaudissements]
moi je crois que la région fait la radio
en raison des choses très important
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je vends donc et enfin gros
bijoux et comme tu as aimé la chanson du
pc passant je restais la chance et est
payé par an
[Applaudissements]
là
je nage dans leur image et ses poissons
enfin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci et puis on vous souhaite une
excellente semaine hors voix khadija et
bonne semaine au revoir c'est tout de
suite vous savez bien pour tout ce qu on
pas une message aujourd'hui va on a
cette habitude de leurs
2 maurice à doc et difool en passant par
radio notre dame la fm offre un panorama
très éclectique d'ailleurs dans cet
espace de parole où chacun inscrit ses
graffitis sonore il ya même des
émissions comme le dit guy chaudes et
fraîches spontanée et conviviale
[Musique]
ils sont hauts occuper ça ça se passe
sur ouï fm et l'animateur s'appelle 4
[Musique]
superbe
du
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression de rentrer sur scène
mange de la radio cette radio la rampe
l'état
ici pas de place au désespoir
ça dépend beaucoup aussi dû tomber ce
que le public est vraiment l'acteur
principal de l'émission
moi je donne la réplique en fait je
pourrais aussi me dis ça comme une
technique qui donnent la réplique
à 5-2
non j'ai 10
[Musique]
un
élève de terminale au lycée champlain
mariant est une fan du ziggy chaud elle
n'est pas la seule dans sa classe ils
sont quelques-uns à partager cette
passion une passion exclusive presque
secteur
enfin ce qu'est bien comme avec ses
quelque chose c'est que c'est convivial
tu prends une radio comme
radio
plus skyrock
je crois qu'elles sont mineures
enfin je sais pas vrai
kikou dit guy chauderon c'est pour
rigoler
t'écoutes fun radio ou autre chose
j'suis pas
c'est pas pour rigoler c'est pour
raconter tes problèmes
font du fric sur le dos des gens qui
sont bien dans leur tête et je suis ça
nul
alors le ziggy show en revanche celle
inverse de tout cela bien sûr vu malice
guichon n'en parle pas on délire
on rigole dessus et l'endroit où ça va
c'est là c'est là c'est l'endroit où il
ya pas qu on se lie nos bulletins qui
sont nuls à chier mais on s'en fout
parce qu on en rigole quoi je sais ça
c'est dit deux ans matt passé s'écoule
pas céder des décennies lot de chevaux
et danseurs
ça nous fait rire enregistré la veille
et à titre d'exemple ce duo entre cad et
marion
il
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
j'ai vraiment le sentiment
que les gens c'est que j'ai on se marre
bien
oui on ne sait jamais
à qui peut t'arriver
un homme on est des ministres
devrait pas cesser notre rhino certains
des deux ministères oui tu sais la chaux
lance dallas autour de la terre
non c'est vrai c'est notre heure de
gloire coiffant moi je passe pausini
chaud je suis juste les rires de but de
troll finale quoi mais
mais c'est vrai que après on est fiers
qu'il ait voulu vachement fier il n'y a
pas de quoi pourtant un mais comme si
c'est vrai que marion c'est devenu
obsessionnel pas elle parle tout le
temps évident dans ces virages séquelles
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une période
une fois on est allés au théâtre un soir
on est rentré déjà j'ai forcé mme amara
matuidi chaud dans la voiture et après
on est rentré on a à peine d'enlever les
chaussures c'est gelé sur le téléphone
en criant comme des folles et on sait
pas pourquoi on sait pas d'où ça vient
c'est comme ça ça rend heureux
c'est bon
duel de rap ou de mauvaises notes
concours de larsen le ziggy chaussée le
club des potaches le cercle des lycéens
qui n'aiment pas les prises de tête
simple sauf
ça pue ça pue non
ça pue
et ça pue
salut à toi là
[Musique]
je suis assez surpris de voir que les
gens ils rentrent dedans mes oies
tranquille fallyssa balance une musique
pour les chambres tout de suite derrière
il cherche même pas à comprendre quoi
les sons et ses manches ce que j'imagine
bien la mecque chez lui dans soit debout
dans sa dans sa piaule ou chez pas dans
le salon et ses parents pas loin s'ils
font la cuisine et ils sont là ils
doivent se cacher je sais pas comment il
arrive à faire ça il arrive des fois où
il est par exemple il ya un mec qui
téléphonent qui ont ils à son père qui
prend le téléphone de l'hôte et c'est
bon alors tu arrêtes parce que j'en ai
marre peu et le téléphone ouais ce que
papa choix la radio tu vois j'ai des
trucs comme ça oui ça c'est d'appliquer
de liga qui fait brillant a aggravé les
choses mais le redressement actuel et
premier poteau ouais ouais d'accord j'ai
produit régulier c'est bien alors mais
ça c'est bien ça c'est bien
[Musique]
on aura une prospère un temps ça va
vraiment prospère 17 ans man c'est pas
possible tu veux tu peux pas passer pour
un bulletin pour les gi joe zawinul
vers 17 ans matt barrie mais prospère
non ça peut pas le faire un jeu violent
que vous vous devez normalement pendant
le bulletin vous devez normalement
essayer de rivaliser que serait le
barbare
situe la jeff ou de 87 points 8 à 107.5
l'afm fonctionne fort chapelle parc
lampard crible selon la fréquence les
mots provoque amusé ou console solitaire
chômeurs laurent delmotte a choisi la
famille des sans sommeil cent mille
auditeurs que la voix de macha béranger
réconforte tous les soirs depuis 18 ans
pour elle ça représente 37500
conversation en direct et 15 mille
heures de micros
macha c'est quelqu'un de très
compréhensifs
madoff
en appelant mme asha on est sûr d'être
écouté mon
on est sûr que quelqu'un va nous
accueillir la façon dont elle dit
bonjour déjà ça en dit long
machin je n'ai jamais vu et pourtant
j'ai écouté beaucoup d'émissions elle a
souvent été maudirai à l'épreuve à sa
place j'aurais complètement fuit
elle s'en sort toujours bien elle a
beaucoup d'humour elle a beaucoup de
fermeté beaucoup de fermeté ça c'est
appréciable parce qu'elle sait mettre
les limites aussi moi c'est comme ça que
je la ressens quelqu'un de tendre et de
fermes en même temps à quelqu'un qui est
qui a vraiment la capacité
d'aimer les autres j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]
macha commence son émission sur france
inter à l'heure où sur skyrock maurice
termine la sienne il est une heure du
matin la tour eiffel c'est à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien je viens vers vous afin de
rejoindre vos rêves sous les étoiles
certains de vos désirs ou quelques-unes
de vos nostalgie racontait toujours très
tendrement 47 et beaucoup de solitude il
ya que de la solitude mais c'est pas la
solitude apparente elle est beaucoup
plus grave
quand vous voyez un sdf sa solitude
s'apparente quand vous allez rendre
visite à un malade sa solitude est
apparente mais les solitude intérieure
qui ne se voient pas qu'ils sont
invisibles or celles là sont très très
grave ces deux solitudes qui on est des
couleurs très très violente qui sont
momentanée et ces gens là n'ont pas la
possibilité de communiquer pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont peur d'être jugé ils
ont peur d'être secoués mais dans le
mauvais sens du terme ils ont peur et
ils ont honte ils n'osent pas j'entends
souvent est-ce que vous pouvez parler
pourquoi est-ce que tu avais raconté ça
à quelqu'un non je n'ose pas j'ai peur
je me sens mal à l'aise j'ai honte alors
chez moi on vient parce qu'on sait que
je suis ni docteur psychiatre
ni juge je donne pas de sentence de ne
pas d'ordonnancé chez kuhn alger une
amie d'une complice aulas
surnommée la vénus de la nuit et doyenne
en activité d émission de libre antenne
machad mais mal les dérapages à l'eau
liberté de parole oui mais en étant
responsable
des petits problèmes
est-ce que vous avez misaine
de vivre j'arrive mai aps un goût de
vivre
le micro c'est même un pouvoir qu'il
faut sans arrêt gérer et c'est un
mondial cette grande responsabilité
surtout dans ce genre d'émission si la
demande
demande de conseil demande de réflexion
et demande de vérité
très dangereux les mots il a fait la
bonne image qui ont pas beaucoup de
violence à la télévision images qui
appelle d'autres images et docks appelle
d'autres actes dans la vie les mots sont
là même la même le même poids pour ça
qu'il faut bien les choisir défaut il
faut travailler sur nos corps de
sensibilité de responsabilité mais je
répète tout peut être autiste une
question de tous deux mots
et
pas dérapé c'est quand même c'est une
forme de respect de soi même et de
respect des hommes comme dans la vie
[Musique]
ensuite je vous souhaite une exquise
venu l écoute de france a peur et de
post kernel et je vous embrasse très
jolie dit au revoir
[Musique]
ouais
alors voilà je te voyais que laisser les
fans du dimanche pour donner
[Musique]